We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 to David P. I am called
out by Troy yawk using one of his many pseudonyms
for not wearing a mask.
Take a listen to this.
Hold on a second.
I guess I hit the wrong button.
Here we go.
Hey, David Pakman.
Woody Underwood from Indianapolis, Indiana.
Sure.
I was listening to your video about my I'm
now wearing a mask.
And what's really funny is that in your video,
you are now wearing a mask.
So how often you wear a mask and why are you
wearing one?
For your stupid podcast, and no one really
watches except maybe bots.
Right.
And you're your gay friends in Boston, both
brutally homophobic.
I think that you ought to take a couple masks,
put some mayonnaise on it.
And some butter.
Yeah.
This guy calls in to the show eight to 10
times a week.
By the way.
So listen, I'm wearing a mask when I go into
any grocery store or post office or whatever.
I don't wear one on the show because I'm at
home.
I'm just sitting in my house.
So it would be really weird to wear a mask.
We have updates on the bonus show about Kim
Jong un.
We will talk about a women's soccer lawsuit
losing an attempt at equal pay.
And we will also talk about a court weighing
in as to whether mass gathering bans should
apply to churches.
I believe that they should.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show get instant access by becoming a member
at Join Packman dot com or a patron at Patry
uncommons slash David Pakman check.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.